what do you think of l.a in hollywood is
it is it uh or do you love it or you
like is this
it's crazy are you a guy that goes out
to these places like whether it's boa
steakhouse or any of these guys
saddle ranch are you one of these like
because you would get you know when you
walk in everybody turns their head
everybody knows who you are
when i walk in it's the same thing
people people often are like oh amy
schumer's here
and and i appreciate that what um what
do you think about like the l.a training
spot trendy [ __ ] like are you into that
[ __ ] is it fun to you or you like ah
it's [ __ ] annoying i mean i love
going to good restaurants and having
good you know good food your boy diablo
goes to boa all the time goes inside
let's see
i see him all the time he [ __ ] loves
steak or whatever all the time
i wouldn't say i'm super into the
trendiness of like you eat food are you
licking either
yeah yeah oh this year especially during
the pandemic i
just that's all i do is that's how i
discovered saddle and stuff cause you
like taco bell i love taco bell yeah and
del taco
and delta now interesting now yeah uh
this is the way i think of both of them
i think del taco might have actually
better food but i think you can talk
about
might have better food no i think
they'll taco del taco doesn't matter
yeah but i think taco bell has more
transcendent moments
and they're just better yeah and like
branding and it's just those iconic
kind of flavors you could tell that
they're better at branding it's a it's
definitely a bigger chain than
you had an incident at taco bell do you
remember what happened what happened to
talk about didn't you throw it you had
like a fit or something
i've admitted by the way i'm just
near your level of notoriety at your age
i would be in jail
but oh the yeah the the food court what
happened to the food court do you
remember
okay i was i had i was with this girl
she's she was beautiful
and of course so you're taking her to
the nice place i'm taking her to a food
court where she should take a beautiful
girl too of course
and uh it's that's a crazy story uh some
some dude who worked at the the food
court i got a wetsuit
i don't even know he's all he's all
dressed up in his uniform
and he comes up and at this time
everybody's trying to take a picture at
the mall
um he he's like yo can i can i take a
picture and i'm like yeah you know i'm
cool with that
and he's like no not of you i want a
picture with your girl yeah that's
[ __ ] up yeah i know that's [ __ ] up
and i it's ridiculous yeah i was like
what the [ __ ] like it took me a minute
to practice like no get the [ __ ] out of
here go back you're literally in like a
little wetsuit pretzel like yeah yeah
yeah little apron
and then i yeah i couldn't i couldn't
let that is that him
is that the wetzel though yeah i
couldn't i couldn't let him go out like
that
i couldn't let myself go out like that
so so he went back to his little stand
after a little altercation
i had a slushie in my head right so and
i've done this many times in life i
don't know why i don't know why i always
have a slushie in my hand
and so i walked over there and just
chucked that up hit him perfectly and
then perfect
he jumped up on the table and at that
time my security is like already
blocking everything
right that was funny yeah who does that
though it's
[ __ ] up to do like props you're taking
a girl out on a date
yeah the food court you expect people to
be classy he came up to me and like
10 of my friends and like had the balls
to just say that you roll deep you
always have an entourage oh yeah i like
that
yeah just there's people as you can see
on the internet that i just have ben i
always take ben i would say
guys better looking than me right there
and then he gets in first and then i'm
screaming and i'm back in the livestream
i'm led into a service entrance yeah
uh yeah but that's crazy but you get you
can and what happened with the hot
cheetos because
oh that was people always ask me if that
was really fake and that's because that
was as real as it gets
i think i made a joke i think i was on
stage at the comedy store and i was like
little zan said he went to the hospital
it was a hot cheetos yeah
what happened was i ate i ate a couple
bags and i've looked this up uh
this could just happen this happens it's
gonna happen i ate a couple bags and i
started puking and
there was a little little bit of blood
in there and i was like well maybe
that's just the hot
no blood looks like a certain way yeah
and i freaked out a little bit went to
the hospital no big deal
like just stop being [ __ ] cheetos
it's just because of your your
background
people are probably skeptical when i say
i'm on the keto diet and i go to dairy
queen and i say
i thought they were giving covet tests
there and i just end up with a blizzard
by mistake
yeah it feels like when you say hot
cheetos a lot of people think yeah and
just
all the media outlets picked it up and
thought it was i don't even know if i
said overdose in the video but there's
he overdosed on some my cheetos and i
was like [ __ ] just wrong with it they
just really are
do you hate them do you hate the media
are you like oh no [ __ ] these people
there's there's certain outlets it's how
they make their money right yeah it's
certain outlet i can't hate on anybody
just doing what they do to make money
you know
right i like tmz and i like uh a lot of
the media outlets
some more favorable than others but yeah